I made it!
Oh my god.
Ok.
Wait one second.
Hi!
Close.
Welcome.
What's going on?
There we go.
Now I can probably hear it.
Oh my gosh.
Panic.
Welcome.
Hi everybody.
Sorry.
I wasn't really prepared.
I was running around trying to...
Oh my gosh.
My Joy-Cons were like, woah, we're low battery.
And I'm like, what are you talking about?
I've been charging this thing all night.
And then I found other ones and then I think it was being silly.
Anyway.
Welcome to Mario Party Jamboree!
I will be playing today with...
With Matara, with Raimu and with Giga.
And I need your guys' help.
I can't choose.
You guys, I want to be Boo, obviously.
I want to be Boo, but this is the first time you can ever play as Toad.
I don't know if you guys have heard my Toad impression, but it's pretty darn good.
It's her birthday.
Happy birthday, Jelly!
Oh gosh, I'm playing also through OBS, so I'm probably going to lose all these mini-games.
Let's do a poll.
Minto, I got paid.
I can super chat.
Amelia!
Thank you!
Wait, let me do a poll.
Start a poll.
Who to play?
Toad, Boo.
I'm polling my chat.
You need to hear your Toad voice before we can decide.
Okay, what do you want me to say?
What do you want me to say?
Okay.
Can we hear your Boo impression?
Sounds like a dying goat, but it's close.
Maybe.
Alright, now what do you want me to say as Toad?
My intro?
Oh wait, most people are voting for Boo though.
Okay.
We need to re-vote.
Why are you playing through OBS?
Because I'm stressed!
Because I wasn't ready.
Oh wait, I guess I could play through.
Hold on.
Wait, maybe I can play through my monitor.
Hold on, I have to change it.
I have to change it, I think.
I think everyone voted before they heard Toad.
SMH.
You guys should have believed me!
You guys should have believed me.
You guys should have...
You should have been like, I have faith in Minto's...
Faith in Minto's Toad voice.
How could you?
I think they're kind of waiting on me.
So I'm just gonna pick Toad, you guys.
We'll pick Toad, we'll pick Toad.
We'll pick Toad.
And of course I'm not gonna talk as Toad the entire time.
But let me...
Let me move this over here.
I have to move everything onto my skinny monitor.
The music's so cute!
And then I'll have to adjust the foogies...
For each person playing.
But who is playing who?
You won't know.
Okay, I'm gonna tell them that I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Okay, I'm not playing through OBS anymore.
We're good.
Let me turn Matara down.
I think last time she was on my stream, she was way loud.
I'm gonna put her at zero.
Hello?
Hello!
Of course you pick up first.
You love me the most.
No, it's because I need to put you at zero.
Bye, Matara!
I can't hear her.
I don't know what she's saying.
Mint!
Can you hear me?
Hi, Lime!
Hello!
I just need a minute to eat.
Because I've been up since like 9.
And I have not eaten yet.
I forgot to eat.
You forgot to eat?
Okay, take your time.
Wait, you said you were gonna wake up at like 6am.
What happened?
Lazy pants?
I'm too tired.
I burned out a little too hard.
You're two days into your subathon, girl.
But it's because I streamed for like 12 hours.
I know.
You chose this.
I did.
I'm so excited.
I'm kind of really looking forward to tomorrow.
Where it's just not a collab day.
Not that I'm not happy being here with you guys or anything.
I think you hate us.
I do.
All of you.
How was your day?
How's y'all doing?
Good.
It's my day off.
So I'm chilling and relaxing.
And no, do not apologize for collab on day off.
It's actually kind of nice.
Do not, do not.
No, no, no.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
It's nice because I get to have some time with my friends.
Even when I'm on my day off.
So I really like it.
Which is cool.
But I have been no-lifing that metaphor game a little bit.
Because it's actually a nice time waster.
It's kind of like, you know, when you play Persona 3.
And you're messing around in the...
Yeah.
It's like a dungeon grindy kind of social aspects game.
It's by Atlus.
It's like new Persona.
Oh, the metaphor game.
I've been wanting to play it.
It's really good.
It looks really good.
People have been braving about it like crazy.
Do you like it?
Do you think it'll be fun on stream?
I think it's one of those games...
So I played it a little bit on stream.
There's not like a ton of voice dialogue.
And I think you can get like a hundred hours plus out of it.
So it's like a huge commitment.
I was like, I could play this on stream.
But I also...
It's a nice game to just play when you're kind of like switching your brain off.
And like grinding out JRPG classes.
So it's like...
Yeah.
So I was like, I'll get it stuck in a place where I'll play it on stream.
Then feel like I can't play it off stream.
So I'm just gonna play it off stream.
And it'll be my chill, like, lie in bed playing it on a Steam Deck.
I like that.
Yeah, it's nice.
Also, I played...
Okay, hold on.
I always feel like I have to talk.
But I'm just actually trying to eat.
Then eat.
You don't have to talk.
Yeah, that's fine.
We'll just sit here in silence.
Let's do that.
Mintz and I have nothing to talk about if you're not participating.
So we're just gonna awkwardly stare at our computer screens until you're done.
Yeah.
Hold on, Matara.
Let me hide my screen.
Hi, Gigi.
Hello.
Hi, Giga.
How was your day?
Good, it's been good.
I was just talking.
For the hundredth time.
About?
Just why cities are good for the thousandth time.
Oh yeah, I'm like an avid London defender.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People are like, hate London.
Matara is like, hate London.
I hate it because in London you'll go get a drink and it's 25 free British pounds.
I'm like, I've been there.
What is London?
I won't defend London's prices, but London itself is cool.
Yeah.
I legitimately thought you guys were talking about like a gacha game at first.
Like, what?
Like some sort of...
I was like, oh.
London defenders.
Oh, you're defending London, oh.
And the train system is really nicely set up.
You can actually live pretty far out from London and go work into London.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I was talking about when I first got my job.
Isn't that the best?
Yeah.
You go home and it's quiet, but then during the day you go to like sensory overload town.
Yeah, I found the one problem with like commuting was that like in my first, I think two months at my new job when I was commuting into London, there was like this huge catastrophic issue with the trains.
And I went into London and it took me two and a half hours to get to work.
And then, and then like three days later, there was an issue while I was already in London and I got stuck in London until like 10pm.
And then so I got home, I got home like closer to midnight and then had to go back into work the next day at like, like get up at 7am for that.
And I was like, I want to die.
Yeah, I usually ended up opting for living very close to wherever I had to work for that reason.
Because like, the thing with the thing with the city is like, the trains say they're on a tight schedule.
And every 15 minutes for some stops, some stops, it's five minutes, you've got a train coming through every single time, you know, and then one train will have an issue.
And then they're like, Oh, your train to go two blocks isn't coming for 45 minutes, you know, so I would just end up walking everywhere.
So I would end up what I decided to do was I was like, I'm going to stop taking the trains for the most part, I am going to walk everywhere.
I'm going to do those long walks, but I'm just going to live a little closer.
And then just do it.
And I did and I was my legs were never stronger than that time.
That's how I know you don't have winter.
Oh, oh, no, it was it was there.
I would dress in like my Michelin Man looking suit of like snow pants and a huge jacket.
I have you on max and you're still a little quiet.
But I cannot make you louder.
I put you at like the loudest you can be.
I'm quiet.
Everyone always says I'm quiet.
Yeah, it's like the game is going to join off of me.
But you need to talk like once you're there's a really long cutscene.
Once you're done with it, we'll talk to like the little radar radar.
That's like you.
And then you join off of me.
Wait, do we have to pick our character first?
I'm not sure.
Oh, wait, I just showed room ID.
But yeah, OK, wait one second.
Let me restart.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
I'm in the party plaza.
Sorry for that.
Let me restart the room.
It's because I'm not used to holding one Joy-Con.
Yeah, yeah.
This is new to me.
Oh, they have huge wiggler.
All aboard.
Oh, OK.
I have the game.
I hit start and then like snooze my switch.
Am I playing the game?
Also, games take much longer.
Oh, yeah?
Do they?
Yeah, there's a lot.
OK, there's a lot more minigames.
Some minigames take a long time.
You also have a buddy system and it takes like a longer time.
So I'm just letting y'all know.
OK.
The games take much longer.
I'm ignoring the tutorial.
I don't...
Atari, you'll have to... You'll have to lead us.
Earlier today I did the volcano.
It was fun.
We just did the mall.
But you guys can pick whatever map we... There's a racing map that looks really good.
But you can also pick whatever map we do.
Wait, so I can get Mario Kart and Mario Party PTSD at the same time?
Great.
Wait, how do I go to like... How do I join your game?
Oh, I think... OK, hold on.
I have to add you.
Hold on.
I saw the invite but it's making me watch this cutscene before I can join your game.
Don't forget about Paratroopa Flight School.
You gotta watch the cutscene for it.
The volcano loomed over this tropical island.
I want both Giga and Lime to rate the tweet that Mint wanted me to tweet earlier.
You wouldn't have gotten in trouble.
I know you.
I think I would have gotten in trouble.
No, you wouldn't.
Would you like to read it, Mint?
I don't have it up.
OK, OK, wait.
I'll read it in a second.
Let me just add you.
I want to read it for y'all.
Just because like...
My chat was like, Starup, please, do not.
They're just a bunch of babies.
You just would have gotten a bunch of bots being like, you need crypto?
OK, you need...
And then I would have gotten a bunch of fake accounts.
And then I would have had 400k on Twitter and like 20 likes.
And I would have been flagged by Twitter.
I was going to say, that's a free band list.
OK, you're right.
OK, wait, let me show you the tweet.
I don't know if it's better to show you or to read it, because it's like...
Just read it.
I don't know.
I can't transfer my money.
You're already fumbling.
Was it hacked?
Help.
I want this on a shirt.
I need help with my essay.
I need art commission.
Can someone draw this for me?
Crypto, wallet, bitcoin, mint.
You're NFTs.
I need a sugar mommy.
My IG was hacked.
Giveaway Gmail hacked.
Instagram disabled.
Twitter hacked.
Help sugar daddy cry.
Like this tweet.
Follow me.
Tag three friends in the comments.
It's like a summoning circle for bots.
Those are always funny.
Yeah, it's just a summoning circle for the bots.
Guys, please, I just joined WME.
Oh my god, you are being so sensitive right now.
They've seen your worst.
Yeah, it's sometimes like, you know, when I'm streaming for like a sponsored stream or something...
and someone's like, can you do this or say this stuff during a sponsor?
It's like, if they didn't know what I'm like, then that's on them.
Yeah, exactly.
If they emailed me for me and they didn't know what I was like...
I'm being a little voyeur.
Okay, there we go.
I just don't want to summon all the bots, okay?
I'm sorry.
Wait, how do I do your invite?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I just took a photo of a guy without his permission.
Okay, so you have to go...
before the hot air balloon.
Before?
When you're in like the big city.
To your right, there's like a little teal thing with a radar on it.
You have to click on it because it connects you to the internet.
And then from it, you join friend room.
I'm just watching Bowser freak out right now.
The game is like showing me all this story and lore and stuff.
I have not taken in a single part of it.
Wait, guys, I know I always play Wario, but they added Shy Guy and I'm a Shy Guy main.
See, that's what I had to switch to.
I had to switch to Toad.
Yeah.
I just play Yoshi because he's cute.
Forever Bowser.
I have to be him.
I have to do it.
I'm never not gonna be Bowser anymore.
This is it.
Sorry, Wario.
My little man.
I have a new ironically chubby little man.
I wouldn't say little.
Yeah, he's a big boy.
Oh, so it's the hot... Okay, the antenna thing.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I'm going into the hot air balloon.
I swear to God, please...
Could not join.
Okay.
Okay, connect.
Because I have to pick my character, hold on.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get a little blanket because I'm still in my workout gear.
And now that I'm not working out, I'm actually getting kind of cold.
I'm here.
Hello.
Oh, I'm pushing.
I can push you.
Let me in.
I'm trying.
Wow, party plaza is so cool.
Could not join.
Could not join?
Do I have to hang on this hot air balloon before I try to join?
When she sent the invite to me, it just said do you want to join Tara's room and let me join.
I didn't have to go into the hot air balloon at all?
Nope.
I accidentally clicked the hot air balloon.
Give me a second.
Let me make sure I'm connected.
Can you see me, Matara?
Do I have to manually enable the online for this fucking game?
Alright, hold on.
I think that's what it is, yeah.
Hold on.
Okay, yeah, there we go.
Am I smacking you?
Oh, how do you smack?
How do you smack?
Am I smacking you?
No, you're missing.
You're missing.
Miss.
I don't know how to smack.
Yeah, how do you smack?
Come here, I'll show you, baby.
No, you won't.
This is like what Mint and I look like when we walk down the street.
Let's gang up on her.
Gang up on her.
Ah, no!
Not the... I knew the small women were bullies.
How do you smack?
No, I was just, like, rolling and saying that I'm smacking you.
I'm not actually smacking you.
Can I join now, Nintendo?
Nintendo, please, let Lime join.
Let me in.
You're the smart one.
It's over for you.
It just says no rooms can be found.
What?
Hold on, let me try to enter this.
Europe.
Oh, I accidentally showed the room ID again, because I clicked the wrong thing.
Should we leave?
I think people can join unless they're my friend, though, but I guess we're gonna find out.
Oh, wait, you're showing up now.
It wouldn't let me do it through the invite, but let me just do it really quick.
Lime's joined, yes!
This is the real... Wait, if you're the real Limes, prove it.
Prove you're the real Limes.
Yeah, prove you're the real Limealicious.
Yeah.
Damn girl, you need sun.
Oh my god, it's her.
The real one.
Alright, into the hot air balloon we go, ladies.
It's time, it's time.
It's not Limealicious, it's Limealicious.
Limealicious.
So where do y'all wanna go?
Wait, what's this over here, over there?
Oh, I unlocked a new map.
Oh, okay.
Do you wanna do it then, since it's a new map?
Take a look at all the maps before you decide.
Western land.
That is really cute actually, though.
I love trains.
You said you did the volcano in the mall?
Yeah, volcano in the mall.
I wanted to do the mall.
Coconut mall.
Party rules or pro rules?
Let's do...
What are we?
Well...
I mean...
I've never... I think we're doing party rules, right?
I think we're all professionals here.
Yeah, we're gamers.
I think it's just basically like what you get rewarded stars for.
Like, party rules is more like arbitrary shit, like landed on the most items.
Party rules is like, you won the most minigames.
Yeah.
It's fun, it's fun to...
The only one I didn't do was the...
I only did the mall and the volcano.
But I'd be really down for the western land or the roller racing.
I think it'd be good for western.
Because if you...
If other people have to unlock it, you know, like it means maybe less people have seen it yet.
World's first western land run.
World's first.
Yes.
World's first, yeah.
Western land run.
So, okay, very quickly.
The first time I played this, it did not take 90 minutes.
It took like a little over 2 hours.
The second time we played this, it was actually almost an hour and a half.
This game is a little longer, but how do y'all feel about 15 turns?
Or do you want to keep it at 10?
What do y'all...
I'm down for anything.
There's a lot more comebacks in this game than the previous one.
I would say like 10 is fine for the first one so we can see like how long each one is for us specifically.
Genuinely, in this game, if you do 15 rounds, I think you can come back a lot easier.
There's a lot of gold multipliers.
There's a lot of ways you can like buy two stars at once.
So you actually could come back.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go!
Betrayal!
I love being betrayed by my small women.
Betrayal.
I don't think we're in luck today.
Has everybody here met?
Oh, wait.
I must be in luck today.
Are you doing your intro now?
Has everybody here met before?
I think so.
Yeah?
I don't know who any of you guys are.
Should we do a small intro?
We could've.
We should've, maybe.
Mint, you also need to speak louder.
Please.
Me speak louder?
Eat the mic.
Eat the microphone.
What was that?
I just had a collab with people who were not say so.
I thought this was like the wholesome collab.
I ate fuzz all over the dust on top of my mic.
If there's anything I'm famously known for, it's definitely for being wholesome.
It's lying maliciously.
Yeah.
I only say nice things in my streams.
I've never been mean, ever.
The milk's so weak!
No!
No, no, Mint!
Wow, Matara.
How could you know?
Mint is at her loudest.
Mint does not get any louder.
Hi!
Okay, I'll turn myself up, but I'm going to be too loud on my stream, I think.
Turn yourself down a bit, then.
What do you mean?
Matara, okay.
How about you turn everyone else down?
I did.
Leave Mint where she is and then turn it up on OBS.
The problem is, Mint is still quiet.
OBS is maxed.
Mint is maxed.
Okay.
Am I louder now?
I'm in the red on my stream.
Really?
Okay.
If you go into voice and video, Mint, do you have like automatic game control enabled or anything like that?
Let me check.
I don't think so, but I'll double check.
I actually have her on 200 Discord.
I promise you, I would not lie about this.
No, I don't have any.
I'm a trooper.
It's okay.
Mint, just remember every time you speak, just speak louder.
Okay!
You can admit, you guys have collabed before?
No.
Introduce yourselves please.
I should have done that.
Sorry, I'm such a bad host and organizer.
I'm so sorry.
Are you ready?
Mint, you go first because you're stinky.
Okay.
Okay!
Here we go!
Hello!
My name is Mint Phantom!
I'm playing as Toad!
Nice to meet you!
Oh, actually...
Do you want Mint?
I might have to have you do an intro again because Limes, I think you should do the intro first.
Because you're the first one on the board.
How do y'all feel about that?
Or, you know, Mint doesn't have to do it again because her voice is gonna fucking collapse.
Where are my stickers?
Can I be a sticker?
Can I use stickers?
Yeah, you can, you can.
If you press down.
There you go.
Oh, maybe not while I'm playing.
Where's the mist?
There's no... They took away my sticker.
This is automatically...
They took away mine too!
Oh my god, so bad.
But there's a sticker store.
Okay, well, maybe Nintendo are selling back my lewd Yoshi sticker, so whatever.
Anyway, my name is Limelicious.
I'm also known as Limu.
I haven't figured out which one of those I'm known by more often, so it kind of makes making new accounts kind of annoying.
But, anyway, I play video games and I'm friends with all of these people because they're nice.
And I like Yoshi.
Friends?
We're not friends.
Okay.
Give it time, give it time.
See what happens.
Why?
Choose my content.
I always roll high on the turn order and then choose roll twos for the rest of the game.
You got a warp box!
Worth it!
Wow, okay.
Okay!
And unfortunately I always invite her on her day off.
Every time.
Hi everybody, Matara Kanvi Shoujo here, Double D's triple threat.
You might know me.
And you might not.
Welcome.
This is my third lobby that I've organized today of this game.
I had five initially but now we're down to four.
So I am a Mario Party expert.
Girl, I'm an organizer.
I'm an influencer.
Oh my god.
I do what I do.
You must love this game.
I just wanted to bring people together for it because I know everyone's too shy to organize stuff.
So I was like, you know what, I'll just organize it.
Why is that?
What do you mean?
Why are they like that?
Why is everyone so shy?
You just gotta DM and be like, video game.
Video game.
I'm honestly really happy to DM people for video games.
I just don't DM people for Mario Party because I'm not into cell smarts.
I only DM when you guys make me.
Maybe after this game.
Alright, who are you, Toad?
I'm Toad.
Nice, I like that.
Yeah.
Kinda looks like you.
No, it doesn't.
What's wrong with you?
Okay, I can only go one way.
See, that is you.
You guys sound the same.
Alright, what about this one?
Hey guys, my name is Tiga from VCO, so I'm really smart and I'm 6 feet tall.
And I really like Shy Guy.
Shy Guy?
What's the average height in this collab?
You a shy guy?
Okay, wait, if you take 3 people that are 4'10 and 1 person, that's 6 feet.
What does it even help you?
Not that tall.
Not very.
Not really.
181 is like 5'11.
If you put 3 4' people on top of each other, that's not 6 feet.
Hey, you guys are taller than me.
Together.
Very good.
Sneak in math.
Okay, thank god I'm not last on the intelligence scale.
At least there's Mint down there with me.
Wait, what are you... That's what you said.
You were like, if you stacked us, then it would be... which is taller.
Is that what you said?
Am I hearing things?
No, I think you're hearing my voice.
Yeah, I meant the average.
Like, you know when you add...
Oh, thank god.
On this tier list, I'm 3rd intelligence, not 4th.
Says you.
That was an intelligence problem.
That was a hearing problem.
Oh my god.
Giga already from the start getting lucky.
I'm trying to...
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
Swap mirror?
I think today is the first day I've ever heard what a shy guy sounds like.
Apparently it was like...
Making car noises, you know what I mean?
Yeah, it's cute.
I need to figure out how to change the settings on my capture card because the colors are so fucking blown out right now that Bowser is almost red.
I need to go tweak the gamma or something.
Sync shots?
Sync jump shots.
Wait, how are you throwing the ball?
There's instructions on the side.
I know, but I don't understand.
Do I have to have two of them?
I'm confused.
Jump and jump shot.
Oh, you can only get into one at a time?
Oh, that sucks.
Oh my god, I might be a pro.
Oh, this is practice.
Oh shit.
Hold on, can I at least try to get one?
Okay, I hate...
Limes is the biggest gamer.
Ready up, Bowser.
Can I at least get one in before we start?
No.
Screw you.
Watch, I'll get last.
I'm gonna lock in.
What?!
Oh, your balls block my balls, so to speak.
Oh my god, lag.
That's my very ball.
Blocking you, I'm so sorry.
I'm balling out.
My bad.
Okay, you know what?
I'm just gonna shoot and hope for the best.
Brother, I am locked the fuck in.
Yeah, you are.
Oh my god.
How do you get the middle rows?
You have to like get it to go in the middle of the big ones.
Oh no, I'm losing.
Oh no.
I'm losing control of my body.
Very nice.
I fucking locked in so hard, dude.
Oh my god, how did you do that?
Once you get the rhythm for a particular row, it's pretty great.
Yeah, I only had the top row.
Yeah, I didn't get the second row in practice, so I was like locking in on the first row, but then the balls were all in there.
And it was like, ah, I see.
Sorry, those were mine.
It's okay, I didn't get last.
It's the first turn, girl.
Watch yourself.
I'm in third place, baby.
Look at the Goomba Hut.
It's my little man!
Okay, if you go to him first, you get money, and then you have like an easier way of winning his game.
He's gonna like hate you though, because you abandoned him.
I didn't.
Yes, you did.
Why would you do that to him?
You also did that to him.
No.
Betrayal.
Oh my god.
Wade.
Wait.
Let's have a look at the store.
Wait, where's the store?
Okay, it's there.
Cadmath.
Unlike me.
God, now I wanna see what the stickers are being sold for.
I know, right?
We gotta win.
Well, actually, Matari, you probably have a lot of money.
You can probably buy a bunch.
Yeah, I could.
Limes, come here.
Come to my side.
Go away from stinky Matari.
Come to our side.
We're cooler.
So everyone but Matari is going in this direction?
Yeah.
Damn.
I told y'all I was gonna get bullied by the short women.
Skeleton T.
Yeah.
Actually, I don't know where the star is at all though.
Maybe Matari is going...
Look, look, look what I can do still!
Oh, you got it.
It's not quite as sus, but we're almost there.
Wait, how'd you get that?
Where'd you get it from?
I hit right.
Right.
Oh yeah, you have the unique Yoshi ones.
Oh, that's right.
These are Yoshi only.
I see.
Okay, okay, okay.
I missed the old one.
This is fine, this is fine.
I did that on purpose, I did that on purpose.
He has to fight Yoshi.
Half the coin.
Alright, you girls are gonna step into my coins, right?
Why would you waste your money?
Maybe.
My love.
Oh, you get half of our coins.
Sorry, I just came from a toxic lobby where everybody was being a little bit sexual.
You're holding on to some anger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, sorry.
What are you doing on back, Mat?
I know, are you okay?
What?
You're like up here, Matari.
You need to come like down here, okay?
I know, I know.
I'm sorry.
You need to come to our level.
No, we're chilling.
We're chilling.
You seem a little tense.
I'm excited for this.
Not me.
I'm ready to fuck shit up.
I'm ready to kill.
I just went crazy in basketball, alright?
I'm ready.
Oh, what's happening?
Howdy, Toad.
Climb aboard me and I'll get you to the next station.
In the blink of an eye.
It is a grandpa train.
Does this cost money?
In fact, I can even go in reverse.
New tech.
Oh, it does cost money.
Can you check the board before you commit?
You can.
It does allow you, yeah.
Okay, that's nice at least.
I was gonna say, I have no idea what the board looks like.
We're actually headed... Actually, only Matara is going the wrong way.
I know, I know.
Listen, it's because any of you can get the star and then the star is gonna move and then I'm gonna be in front of the star.
Okay.
Watashi wa star.
Won't be needing a ride?
Well, I reckon I'll do.
Take care now, Toad.
Why aren't you hitting the ride?
Because I don't need to.
You suck.
She does this thing, Matara, where she looks at the map.
Why would you do the wrong thing like me?
How much money do I have?
Planning thing.
Hold on, do I have a little bit before my turn?
I'm gonna go look at the settings on my capture card.
Let's go see.
Oh, I can move the star.
Oh my gosh, wait, if I get this and then it is in front of Matara...
Yeah, that would be great.
Do that, do that.
Okay, I will.
Thank you.
You're so sweet.
You're such an angel.
I know.
That's why you invited me.
With the lips of an angel...
Uh-oh.
What's gonna happen?
Metal gear.
Let's find out.
Oh, oh no.
I think I'm gonna die.
She's already dead.
Nice try.
He's fucking dead.
I just got run over by a train.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, are you back at the start?
Yes, I'm back at the start.
Oh, Mint, have you tried looking at a map when you're walking?
Have you tried looking at a map, Mint?
You're going the wrong way.
Nobody is getting this star now.
Witness me.
No,
I don't have coins.
I don't have any money.
Yeah, you do.
But then I can't be doing all this.
Oh wait, you actually...
It would have been so funny if you went left.
Wait, how many?
Oh my god, wait, she has a cow!
Look at that horse.
Mint clutches the star.
I think we need a Giga Keith emote as well.
It's about time.
We're gonna make out.
You want all this body?
Imagine making out with Shy Guy.
That's what you're asking for, Matara.
I mean, that's my favorite.
His open...
I can't even say it.
Is this the Say So collab?
Do we have to be?
You know, what do you want to say?
His open, wanting mouth, Matara.
It's right there.
Look at it.
I see three holes.
You were like, wait, can I say this?
I thought it was gonna be something so much worse.
No, no, no.
This is very normal for the book.
Mint reads books on stream about this, so you're fine.
I don't read them on stream.
Oh, what are you doing to me?
Toad will trade all of their coins.
Wait, why is it the other way around?
No, no, no.
You get it, you get it.
Look, you're rich now.
Oh, I have more money!
Yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing wonderfully.
You must be nice.
I fucking hate this game.
Gosh darn it.
Also speaking of good shy men, I mean, all my ex-husbands that were tragically eaten...
have been good shy men.
Wait, what'd you say?
I'm coming for him.
What'd you say?
What's your type?
Yeah, good shy men.
Flicked coins.
Oh, you can die.
Thanks for checking for us.
I really appreciate that.
But you come back.
Wait, can I... I can actually intrude on your seesaw.
That's great.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can do this.
Oh, I keep thinking of you.
No, you... I don't like this one.
You can die.
Oh, wait, did I click on the stars?
I think I'm good.
I don't understand.
Out of the way.
Out of the way, woman.
These are giving me, like, no stars.
Well, take my money.
I'm gonna get my money back.
Jump on my side.
Yeah, jump on the side.
Wait, what the freak?
You can collect them when you're being lifted back onto the ground.
Yeah, you can collect them when you're being lifted.
Oh my god.
Please.
Minto Gaming.
Limes, what's going on with us?
Can we get some Limes right now?
For energy, please.
Mint, I saw you power ball, like, at the end there.
You went crazy.
We're all doing well.
We all sing.
I mean, I was doing okay until someone stole my fucking coins in an event I wasn't even involved in.
She lost more coins, girl.
I got ran over by a train.
I think we all have had a bad day, okay?
Cause you had a bad day.
You thought Lime and Mint were the same person?
I swear to god, they see green.
If I was green, would you also think I'm the same person?
Probably.
You'd have to get short hair.
You're way more annoying.
A fairly good chance that I'll go to someone that's helpful for me.
And then there's also a chance that something terrible will happen.
Wait, maybe it's actually good for you.
I think it is good for me.
Wait, you're not teleporting me back.
You're coming with me.
Hey, girl.
Hey, what's up?
Is it still 20 coins for a star?
Fuck yeah, it's still 20.
You're doing amazing, sweetie.
Thanks.
You're doing great.
Not every game that you play, you're gonna win at.
But that's okay.
I don't think I've ever won Mario Party.
I hate this game.
Really?
There was one time when I almost did and then the game gave like three stars to someone for some nonsense and I was like...
Yeah, it does that.
Tara is thinking.
I'm trapped.
You put that there because I'm coming around the bend, aren't you?
You did that.
She's coming around.
I did that.
You did that on purpose.
People are saying you don't play to win, you play to have fun.
Negative.
I play to win.
It's not enough that I win, others must lose.
Giga, you stole that vote from me because you joined before me, you jerk.
Huh?
Sorry, before we sang.
No, I was saying I actually have made peace with Mario Party and I just play to mess around with the minigames.
You know when you play Among Us?
I've decided I won't play Among Us anymore, but if I did have to play Among Us, I'd literally just disassociate and play the minigames.
That's fair.
It's not fun.
For the gate, do I need a ring?
Oh yeah, I do need a ring.
Shit.
So it's gonna be here.
A what what?
I need a key.
When I said ring I meant...
Yeah, she meant key.
A ring.
I feel like I should've put a key in it.
Yeah, that's the lyric.
One of you get close to the key.
Do it.
Warp with me.
I dare you.
It would be so funny.
Wow, I love being here.
The little fist.
He has little Arthur fist.
Okay, nobody's close.
Okay, good.
Here I go.
Make it good, make it good.
Oh, that's my lucky number.
What is that?
A creepy.
I love you so much, you know that?
Have I told you?
What?
What'd you say?
Have I told you how great you are and how much I love you?
I just wanna make sure you don't forget about that.
Why are you telling me this?
Because I care.
About what?
About your feelings.
It's time.
The rich just get richer.
He's going.
The rich get richer.
Wait, Giga is only 16 coins.
You're the richest.
No, no, she has a star.
And she's about to get like 13 more coins.
Oh my god!
My best man.
Out of my way.
He's zooming.
He really is zooming.
Oh, you should hitch that ride.
Maybe.
Actually...
Yeah, you should.
Catch a ride.
Actually, don't.
This is so cute when you're thinking.
I know, the little shy guy thinks he's so cute.
I can't because then I would skip the milk barrel.
I gotta go.
You gotta get the milk.
Yeah, you gotta go.
I'm gonna be so full.
Of milk.
I'm gonna be so full of milk.
Last time I heard someone being full of milk, they said they were sloshy.
It was in the book.
Is there something like that in your book?
Yeah, it was in the book.
I don't know if the girls know about that book.
They'll learn someday.
Wait, you have to...
I'm just bouncing on top of you.
Don't bounce on top of me.
That looked awful.
So you have to avoid the spikes.
Okay, got it.
I feel like me having a big hitbox is actually bad for me.
I feel like this is not my game with the big hitbox.
It's actually not good.
You wanted to be a big man.
I wanna be a big, strong, sexy man.
I couldn't get out.
Oh man!
Oh my god!
Glorious.
You are gone.
I don't like your big legs.
I'm a big, strong, sexy muscle man.
Cool coins just give me nothing.
New turn.
Wait, he's gonna leave.
Matari, you gotta get to him.
Oh, do my bad.
You're a man.
I'm a man.
Wait, I don't even know where he is on the board.
Whoopsies.
I didn't even look.
It's okay.
I'm gonna hit my first good dice block.
Here we go.
You ready?
Do it.
Lucky number.
Oh my god.
Not red.
Nice.
I think that was pretty lucky.
Where are you gonna go?
Oh, sorry.
I was thanking people for being very kind and sweet.
Can I?
Warp.
It would be really funny if I switched with Giga.
Or me.
It would be less funny if I switched with you.
But you know what?
You know what?
I live for the meme.
For the joke.
Alright, everybody?
Do you believe in miracles?
Warp.
I'm closing my eyes.
I'm gonna judge by your guys' reactions.
Hey, what's up?
How's it going?
Welcome back.
We'll be in contact again, I guess.
I missed my content wife, Yoshi.
I'm so glad to be back with her.
He got, like, separation anxiety after, like, two spaces away from me.
That's so silly.
I just miss my Felicias so much.
Wait, where is your truck?
You ever have that?
When, like, you leave your house and then you come back and you're like, My cat!
You go back to get something and you're like, My kitty!
I just wanted to hug you again.
I love you.
Why did you put the half coin on the lucky thing?
Why did you have to do that?
Snick, remember you can blow the whistle.
It would be so funny if you did that.
You get a star for using a lot of items.
What if you do?
Oh, and I have a creepy dice.
Yeah, you do.
I think I'll blow.
I think it's time to blow the whistle.
I just came from an unstable lobby.
I'm so sorry for laughing.
Where's it gonna go?
Nobody knows.
Oh my god, Chain Chomp is so cute.
What?
No way.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Wait, it's right next to her?
This is so messed up.
I can smell it from here.
I hate this game.
This game hates Toad.
See, I was having an eternal crisis because I was gonna go north for the milk or south for the star.
And I was like, I really don't want to pick between them.
And now I can have both.
God damn it, this is unfair.
Oh my god.
Welcome to the hop along Mario Party for dice rolls.
This is what happens to me every time.
Now I understand.
I wonder where I'm gonna go.
Now I understand why you don't organize Mario Party collabs.
This is why nobody plays Mario Party.
For me?
Don't mind if I do.
Alright guys, everybody get...
Get...
Get Giga.
I can't stand up on Giga.
Everybody get down.
So true.
Alright everybody, we're bullying Giga.
It's her turn.
Hold on, I have to get my milk first.
Did they put it right in front of fucking Giga again?
Again?
That's illegal.
No way.
No.
She doesn't have the money.
There's about to be a minigame.
A shy guy raised his little arms.
Bonus minigame, get double the coins.
Giga has to straight up come forth.
Otherwise she gets another coin.
I'm locking in.
It's a quiz.
Oh no, I'm so...
I saw you on Jabroni Mike's quiz show.
Can I study these images of the balls and then answer the question?
Wait, no, this is a visual memorization quiz.
Oh no.
Fuck you game.
Doesn't Giga have good visual memory?
Giga brain's good.
Oh okay, actually this one isn't so bad.
No, my brain...
My brain do the no visual memory thing.
Wait, what?
Am I dumb?
Surely the question won't be evil.
Don't worry about it.
If the questions are like that, it's not so bad.
But if it's like how many pink stripes are on the front of each ball...
I'm so fucked.
I don't even know what they're gonna ask about.
We should know what the question is first.
Oh my gosh.
I'm looking at the stripes now.
Look closely at fucking what?
How many times did each toad rotate?
Why do these guys look so similar?
It's not fair.
Oh my god.
Which one is in the middle?
Gee, I wonder.
Oh, you had to press.
I had to actually think about it.
I didn't realize I had to confirm.
Yeah, me neither.
Oh, and it's by the time!
Okay, okay.
I did not know.
We're so fucked.
What the hell is that?
What is that?
I can't tell.
Toad, please.
Toad, I don't know what that is.
Oh my god.
What?
Which one wasn't there?
Oh, fuck.
I think I picked the wrong one.
Yeah!
Please be that.
That's it.
So I can win.
We have like one more and we must continue the Giga-cucking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody picked the wrong answer.
We have to pick the right answer.
We gotta pick it quicker than Giga.
Okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
I don't like this.
My game is like stuttering too.
What?
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, I don't fucking know.
Oh my gosh.
I still got more points.
Giga, you're the worst person I've ever met.
But Giga had to straight up lose.
Giga had to straight up lose.
That's a random one and won.
You wanna know the secret?
I actually knew the answer.
I was just saying that so you wouldn't copy my answer.
Oh.
So you wouldn't get the points.
I was just like, if Giga wins, then I get points too.
And I'll move up.
That was my thought process.
New turn.
Bye.
A new turn in this jinx-fucking game.
I'm so sorry.
He didn't feel your love.
You're very gorgeous to me.
You're my erotic and chubby little man.
It's very weird going first on a turn where you know the star is gonna move.
Because it's like, what do I pick?
Because the game could just decide to just screw me over again.
You don't have a key, so you have to go on.
I do have a key.
That's the direction.
I was going this direction specifically.
Oh my god, no.
But there's nothing I can do.
I mean, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
If I roll high enough...
That's happening a lot.
I'm rolling really high.
I'm rolling so high this entire game.
Motherfucker.
I do not want to use the key.
I hate keys.
I'm so fucking sorry, dude.
It's fine.
This is just...
I genuinely hop along the fucking board every time.
Get another key.
It's good.
Oh yeah, another key, imagine.
Two keys.
One key that I'm not using.
Two key.
Alright, Matara.
Alright, it's my turn.
Just because I love you.
Sometimes roll low.
Are you...
Oh, Mint, you know what would be so funny?
What?
Use your curse block on her.
Come on.
I should have saved my whistle.
Wait.
Use your curse block on her.
Because then she's gonna have a chance to step on one.
Wait, I'm live?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why are you so mean?
I thought we were good.
I thought we were going against Giga.
Yeah, but sometimes...
You gotta flip the script...
Because it's funny.
You know you wanna do it, it would be funny.
Come on, Mint.
Oh no.
You know what might be funnier?
It might be funnier to use it on Mata for suggesting something so fucking mean.
What if I made it random and we let it up to chat?
Here we go.
What if it's you?
Then that's my curse.
Oh no.
It's karma.
I just lost guard train over Giga.
It's karma for you.
Oh my god, I'm never getting anywhere.
Please let me through this fucking round.
Have you actually left the first section of the board yet?
No, I haven't seen anywhere.
Giga, get a one.
Giga, please get a one.
So sad, Matara.
This is so messed up.
Yes!
Ultimate power.
Look at him, he's so happy.
Look at his happy face.
I think that's what he said.
The rich get richer.
I think I'm gonna become a landlord.
Oh my god, it's right down the road from her!
Are you kidding me?
Wait, but you still have my room.
I'm paying you.
I think it's 20 gift subs a day for my room.
Well, now it's 40.
I can't afford that, that's a lot of subs a day.
Oh wait, you're poor, yeah, you can't get it.
Poor with three stars, sure.
Poor warrior used to be.
What is it called when you're asset rich?
When you own houses but you don't have the cash to furnish it?
Asset rich, I think?
Oh yeah.
I'll call you land rich, money poor.
You have time to get enough.
This is still messed up.
I'm breast rich, mine poor.
Do the...
Thwomp.
Thwomp the difference.
You wanna thwomp, girl?
Hey girl.
I like the thwomp.
Find the unique image behind the protective thwomp.
Wait, sorry, I didn't know what I was pressing.
Yeah, you actually have to like...
Wait, what am I supposed to press?
You actually got it right!
Oh, I got it right!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Oh no, I have boomer reaction time.
Wait, it says like...
You have to pick the one that's unique.
Oh, okay, I see, I see.
Oh wait, no, the apples had different...
The apples had the different leaves on them.
Oh my gosh, so it's not just easy.
Why can't it be... And you can't change your answer once you pick.
This is messed up.
Oh, they're different directions!
Okay.
Yeah, so we made a Mistake.
I followed you.
You made the Mistake.
Wait, it says to use the face button.
Oh, I was gonna say to select the picture.
I was like, there's only three.
No, there's four!
Now there's four.
I'm scared, I'm scared.
Me too, but I think I'm good.
After this I gotta pee though.
Thank you girls, for permission.
Ah, this is messed up.
Wait, I'm scared.
Wait...
Which one was it?
Which one was it, Giga?
Oh, by a millisecond.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm sweaty.
I'm sweaty spaghetti.
Grape!
Banana!
What?!
How are you guys so fast?
Mint, you were so cute and you gave me energy.
Mint, you being cute actually gave me energy.
I love cute girls, you know this.
I call lag.
Wait, what was that one, the first one?
Oh, are you sure?
Yeah.
I'm so fuckin' sure.
Because we knew it was like an apple.
I didn't realize it was an apple.
Giga, no!
I'm losing.
I need two more rounds.
Wait, what?
Okay, they're all bananas.
Bananas.
Stop it.
Eat, eat, eat apples and bananas.
Oh, and then a fourth one.
Oh my god.
Why is there more?
I'm so tired.
I'm so fuckin' tired of this.
What?
I hope I'm right.
What's wrong with you?
Actually, I think you're right.
What?
You were right.
Yay.
Oh my gosh, Lions, we tied.
Hooray.
If we could not have any more visual memorization games, that would be great.
Right?
There's a worst game where you have to put keys in a gate.
It's probably the worst game, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe I'm kinda smart.
Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
Let's give it time.
Stretch.
What?
What do you mean final five turns?
I haven't even moved it yet.
Five turns.
I promise, every time I've said the games take a long time, they haven't taken a long time.
I'm sorry.
It's okay, then we get to do two maps.
Yeah.
I hope they tell that I'm gonna be the one who they think will win.
You actually, no, you get to decide for a reward.
You know what you should do?
What?
Bowser's face.
You already know.
Wait, what was that?
Star Steal.
Giga.
I have some Korean fried chicken.
You're making it go so fast, I can't read.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to.
Wait, what did they say?
We've never played this.
Yoshi, roll a one.
Come on.
Well, that's what I've been doing all game.
Another one.
Come on, who's my good girl?
Give me a one.
Go pee.
I'm gonna have my turn after, so I'm gonna pee after.
And then we'll start the...
Maybe the one wasn't such a bad idea.
This could be good.
This could be great.
Steal everything.
He's so big.
Don't ask me why I'm the small cousin.
Lose one star.
What?
Oh my god.
He scammed you!
He scammed you for real!
At least I didn't get robbed, I guess.
I'm gonna be right back, hold on.
Imposter Bowser?
I've never even seen that before.
You're welcome.
I really appreciate that.
Yeah, put that down, like, right in front of...
Giga, you know?
Actually, we should all put ours right in front of Giga.
I'm not close enough to Giga.
Oh, it has to be close?
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, is it, like, two spaces out from you?
That's what it looks like.
Then save it, save it.
So sad.
Give me one second, hold on.
She's hacking.
She's gonna change the game rules.
She's gonna hit the lag switch and we're all gonna lose.
She's gonna unplug her internet.
Wait, what?
Alright, I'm here.
What's up?
Where'd you go?
Heavenly raided me.
I'm gonna be playing with them afterwards as well.
Oh my god, you have the whole day.
I have the whole day, baby.
My last collab cancelled, so it's just gonna be Mel and I either doing webfishing or powerwashing.
I love webfishing.
Hey, you wanna help her?
We're not getting a spy on the air.
We can't do it early enough.
And I think I'm gonna max on my...
Anyway.
Sorry, girls.
We showed you only things.
Alright.
Can I kill Giga?
I think I could try.
Do they sell a gun in the shop?
I have six coins, two train stops and a dream.
Go, go, go.
Giga stole my quote, by the way.
Giga came to Vishojo before me and her quote was, it is not enough that I win, others must lose.
You can't choose which way you go, Madara.
Giga, Giga, Giga, come on, come on.
Ah!
Am I two stations back, though?
Where's the second station?
No, you're not.
Oh, I'm behind it?
Who's that?
Wait, yeah.
Wait, what?
Two for one!
I'm such a gamer girl.
I can't get anywhere on this fucking place.
I gotta pee.
I'm gonna piss myself.
No!
Oh my gosh!
I got a two for one.
Five collateral damage at this!
Call imposter Bowser on an opponent?
Oh my god.
Imposter among us.
Do it for Giga, do it for Giga.
Yeah, I have to.
Oh my gosh, you got so much stuff.
What happened?
But the thing is, I don't wanna duel Giga.
I can't wait.
Okay, it's my turn.
Alright.
You're doing amazing, Mint.
Just keep going forward.
This is just my afterlife, man.
Two steps forward, fifty steps back.
All the damn time.
Which way should I...
Okay, I'm gonna do it here.
Because if I do it here, you could always just go that way.
There's only one choice.
Okay, here I go.
I hope I don't get two.
Three!
Oh wait, you have to get one.
Okay.
Alright, get one!
One!
What if I just did this?
Giga, no.
Giga, no!
Let's just say I could use an item...
and be safe.
Is it Matara?
Why was Giga back at the start?
Why is Matara now back at the start?
What the fuck did I miss?
No!
Why is Mint crying hysterically?
What the fuck did I miss?
No!
Wait, what did I miss?
Hey, Matara, you...
Hi, Matara, it's fine, don't worry about it.
How?
I just went for a walk, you know?
How did she do this?
Giga, you used the mirror, you little shit!
Lime, I squished both of them.
I squished both of them.
I've been hit by a train two times.
She's been hit by the train again!
No, please, no, please!
Stop it!
Oh my god!
Just barely, just barely!
You have another mirror, I guess.
I do.
Everyone's gonna be down here with me.
Okay, Matara, don't get a one, okay?
That's awful.
Why?
I want a one.
1v3!
I see.
Squeaky shakedown!
What does this mean?
Wait, what is this?
It's the team side with the squeaky.
Oh god, the lag is so bad.
The lag is so bad!
Oh my god, it's really bad.
Like, it's stuttering.
Why me, why me?
Because I'm lagging so much I don't know if I can actually get to the others.
Stop!
Just go for Giga!
So Giga has not enough coins.
Giga's not winning on coins.
Giga's winning on the 18th coins.
But Giga needs less coins to get enough so she doesn't get the next one, too.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to get enough stars away from anyone to prevent them from dying.
It's okay, you can have mine.
Oh, that's so kind of you.
I love your kitty.
It's so bad, the whole thing is like stuttering.
Can you guys hear that my voice is like a little bit out of it?
Is it?
Girl, stop!
She sounds similar to me.
I definitely feel like I'm still Raspi, but...
It always sounds worse in your head.
Like, from your ears than it actually sounds.
You don't sound so bad.
Oh my God.
I sound great, Minze.
Say that.
Say I sound great.
You're making me distracted.
You're ruining my luck.
You're ruining my day.
You're ruining my time.
You're ruining the game.
Yay,
we're all winners.
Yoshi presents at the end of every minigame.
You haven't noticed?
I have so many coins and nothing to do with them.
You might get a star at the end.
Where it's like, oh my God, coin lady, here you go.
If we were playing with 15 turns, once you get a friend...
you can actually buy 2 stars at a time with them.
So you can pay 40 gold to buy 2 stars if you have the little buddy, like Wario was.
And you can get a ghost that you steal a star from somebody.
Matara, don't forget your Bowser thing.
You should do 2 spaces, Limes.
What?
2 spaces?
Oh, shut up.
She doesn't have a star.
I mean, it doesn't matter because I don't have a star.
Don't go 2 spaces, Limes.
Put it on top of Bowser, it's just the whammy.
You can't, unfortunately.
I guess we'll just trap this entire hallway.
We're all at the beginning though.
Yeah, well, I don't have time to get all the way back to you guys.
Wait, where am I even going?
Hold on.
You can take the train, you can crush another soul.
You could.
Where the heck is the star?
Oh, it's all the way back there.
Giga sounded so smug.
I mean, it's not really near anybody, right?
Because you guys have to go around to get to it.
I don't think that's how you say that.
You can get milked!
I can get milked?
Get milked!
Milk!
I'm gonna get that Wiggler milk.
Look at him.
Hey buddy.
Howdy.
You can invite opponents over for a fun time.
Would you like to invite someone to share?
Come on, Limes.
I'm not winning, so I'm gonna invite everyone for some milk.
You can all come back up here and we'll make a race for the star.
Hoot nanny star!
Alright, we're coming.
Hi!
I guess we're gonna have a hoot nanny.
What's going on here?
Why does the milk look all weird?
It looks like specks in the glass.
Yeah, I don't know if I like milk.
Are you all ready?
I don't think I'm ready.
Oh, I see.
The glasses are spotted and then they filled them with milk after.
Oh, so the whole purpose of this, apart from the fact that it's milk related...
is you get to drag people around the board.
I see.
Don't forget your item.
Don't forget the Bowser.
Okay, everybody do a race to the star.
Yeah, race to the star.
Here we go.
How many am I awake?
I can do three, but I don't know if I can do nineteen in three.
It's kinda crazy.
You would have to get... No, no, cause...
Yeah, you couldn't.
Do it.
Ring ring, Moshi Moshi.
What's that?
You know someone who wants to meet me?
Yeah, I do.
Well, I'm not loyal to my fans.
I'll give them a call myself.
Giga's a loyal fan.
It's imposter Bowser.
He's totally a different Bowser, guys.
Wait, who is it?
Wait, how did you know that I wanted to pick Giga?
It was random.
Oh my god, that's so scary about this game.
Hey Giga, you must lose a star.
Giga's gonna get the thousand coins thing and it's actually gonna give it to Giga.
Right?
Come on, Giga.
Lose a star.
Bowser, what is this?
Wait, what is this?
Everyone gets the same number of coins.
This is the worst.
This is bobbinism.
I like how we're all at like second now because nobody has any stars.
I know, we're all winners.
No way.
All of us are equal, but some are more equal than others.
Adam and Barb, why?
Four legs good, two legs bad, am I right?
Giga, you're the champagne socialist.
What's going on?
Yeah, I'm the most equal out of all of us equal people here.
She got her three stars and then she's like, we should all have two coins as well.
The rich gets richer.
We have the same money, so we're the same, guys.
I have the least coins, so I'm not really gonna complain.
I just spent 20 coins getting milk for everybody, so you know, I consider it death root.
She spent our coins.
This is the furthest I've been on the board.
How does it feel?
Feels good.
Oh no.
Wait, why?
Oh my God.
Oh, a duel.
How many coins?
OK, all in.
Bet all 53.
Yeah, all in.
I am.
Are you betting all 59?
No, you choose to bet.
Oh, I see, I see.
I can go high.
Oh, I can only go up to 53.
OK.
Let's go.
Let's go, Mick.
You come up behind me.
I always go all in.
I'm gonna lose.
Let's go, Mick.
Mick, I'm seeing you for Thanksgiving.
I know.
I will remember this.
I'm gonna lose.
I mean, you might be giving thanks for the coins you're about to get, potentially.
Do a ground pound.
Do a ground pound to spin the hat and hit your opponent, and then dodge it with a jump.
The opponent dodging, the hat gets...
Like those slap competitions.
Why did it hit you first?
Oh.
Ground pounding slightly earlier.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
I'm smaller.
OK, OK, I see.
I know your game, I know your game.
I like this, I like this.
Oh gosh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
Slap him.
I like how it's literally like a butt spanking animation.
Please.
I want to live.
I like it so.
What?
Yeah.
I'm still surprised you didn't just jump ever.
Yeah, I was just ground pounding the whole way.
I thought you could just ground pound.
I'll take your 106 coins, baby.
Guys, do you remember when I had... I used to rule the world.
I had 83 coins.
I used to rule the world.
I used to rule the world with no stars.
That's impressive.
This is before socialism came.
OK, I live in the here and now, you know what I mean?
You gotta let go.
Why would you do this?
I dare you to put it two ahead of you and then roll two.
I dare you.
Imagine.
What if I didn't?
I don't think it's gonna work because she's just gonna give the star to herself, right?
Yeah.
Wait.
No.
Please, no.
God.
No, no, no.
No!
Please, God.
I just...
Pikmitara, please.
Please, Pikmitara.
Please, don't do this to me.
She can't Pikmitara because Pikmitara has no coins.
No, please, God.
Please, God.
You should have done random.
I earned my coins.
Look at this mercy being displayed right now.
Why are you being nice to her, huh?
Gigi isn't about kicking people when they're down, unlike some people, apparently.
I would never kick you girls when you're down.
You're just always short, so I'm always kinda kicking you.
You have 10 seconds to decide where to roll a ball.
Take out as many stones.
What's a stone?
Oh, I see.
It's a bowling ball thing.
Yeah, it's like bowling and you gotta try and figure out...
by visually planning it, which I'm really good at.
You have the eyepatch.
You have like...
Oh my gosh, wait.
No.
How are you doing this?
What?
Okay.
Alright.
One more practice round.
No, I'm good.
I'm just ready to... I'm ready for...
Look at the Moai.
They're so funny.
Wait, why are their faces like that?
Oh my god.
Is it at least a different spread each time?
Yeah, it looks like it.
Right, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna get as close as yours is.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna switch at the last minute, you know?
I did, I did.
No.
I believe in you both.
No, please.
We're gonna do great.
No, no, no.
Bounce, bounce, bounce.
Oh my gosh.
Mint collected.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Mint is making bank right at the end.
Please only be one round.
Yeah!
It's my coin.
Stop challenging me!
Stop!
No, I'm gonna roll one.
That's what I've been doing.
I actually don't think I've hit one the entire time.
It's mostly been two.
Wait, what's going on?
Two to four.
I'm gonna get the award for most coins collected, I think.
I'm gonna get the award for most times crashed by train.
Least spaces walked, moved.
Is there a star award for literally nothing fucking happened to you this game?
I got an award for least spaces moved.
Oh, that's me.
Jump to dodge light waves.
Attack your opponents by doing a ground pound.
Oh, it's literally just the same game except it's light waves instead of a slappy hand, which is less fun.
Oh, yeah.
And it's like a lot of things you have to...
Do you have iframes while you're ground pounding?
No.
No, you don't.
You do not.
Okay, I'm ready to die here.
Are you ready to die?
I'm ready to die.
You wanna play a game?
Trying to distract me.
I think lag... Oh my god.
I knew it.
I think it's the latency.
Oh, what?
Oh my god.
I died too fast.
Nice.
I present in celebration.
I do have EU latency on every fucking game.
It's true.
Didn't you guys... When you played Deadlock, what did you guys play it on?
I made Bricky play on Europe when it was for us, and then when... After that Steam went down, so they switched it up and we were on EU... I'm sorry, East US.
Yeah, because I'm East Coast, so I was able to...
That's a good US.
Yeah, so Giga was like...
The West is a good US.
Good US.
Yeah, if it had been West Coast, I might have just been like, you know what?
You guys have fun.
Like 300 of us.
But Bricky can deal with that, that's fine.
I don't care if Bricky has to deal with it.
He can suffer.
He's suffering.
He's actually in the mines right now.
He's packaging my merch as we speak.
In the mines.
Can I look at the board?
Wait, if I take a ticket, where will I go?
Find out.
Wait, please.
No, I think I go past the star, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Which...
This is a perfect hashtag ad.
When y'all filled out your form, what did you guys get for merch from me?
I sent out a little form to some friends, so they can have some merch.
Giga, did you even fill in your form?
Be honest with me.
I think I did.
Can you please fill it out?
Because stuff is about to sell out, Giga.
Please.
Okay.
So, question.
With the train, I assume if I ride it, I will go past the star.
You cannot, like, get off halfway.
No, yeah, you go past it.
Try it.
Mataracon.shop No, but if she goes the other way, then...
Look, I'm standing right there.
Please.
Look how cute I am.
Kill her.
Please, stop.
Please, I'm just a little guy.
Please.
How many turns do we have?
We have two turns.
We have three turns, right?
I'm not getting this fucking star, am I?
Oh, no.
Wait, Lime.
I'm just a little guy.
Ew, what's up?
Lime, you brought us all here.
Why would you send me back?
Lime, kill her.
I brought you to the top of the board.
I can send you back to the bottom of the board.
Look how happy he looks just standing on the railroad tracks.
He shouldn't be there, but he doesn't know any better.
I'm not winning, so maybe I just opt for chaos, I guess.
No, please.
I am curious.
Did any of you get the daki?
Because you want to hug me in the night.
I did not get the daki.
I did not get a daki.
Oh, wait.
All of us got it in the beginning.
You guys.
You could be hugging me.
They all hate me.
All these small women hate me.
Kill me!
You're gonna die too!
Bitch!
That was worth it.
That was absolutely worth it.
It was not really a strategic decision as much as a funny decision.
Yeah.
Hey, sometimes funny is the best strategy.
You have to pay for the ticket and then you have to pay for the ride?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Wait, where does one stop take me?
Oh, OK.
So it takes me all the way to the bottom, which I don't want, so...
He's like, you called me all the way up here and then you don't want to stop?
What the fuck?
Well, just try for the star.
You can get it.
Sure.
Oh!
What's happening?
What is this, too?
Oh, he's driving.
He's going again.
Oh my god.
No, you don't get hit.
You're in the green zone.
I'm back where I belong.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, wait!
Wait, if Giga gets one, then I get her star.
Alright, how far is the star?
Are you guys kidding me?
Giga has the mirror though, so Giga's just going straight back up here.
You know that.
Oh, true.
What's the fist?
What is that?
I think it's a dueling glove.
Oh, I can't?
Oh, because I don't have a star.
Dammit.
You can't win.
You could only duel for coins.
No, it wasn't even letting me pick the item, unfortunately.
Oh, what the heck?
Oh, okay.
La la la la la la, watashi wa star.
Watashi wa star, watashi wa star.
Oh, wow, that was so fast.
I did that by accident.
Oops, you should cover that song, guys.
You're just...
But yeah, Gigi, get your stuff now before it sells out, please.
I did, I already did it.
Did you get a doki so you can hug me?
No.
Okay, let me see what Gigi got.
I don't have a pillow.
You suck.
Why does nobody want to hug me?
I have a doki and it is 3 inches.
It is a mini keychain doki.
That's all I have.
Oh, I have one of those too.
Yeah, I got one of Mint Nuke.
Okay, you got the standee, the keychain, the raid poster and the sticker sheet.
Nice.
What did Mint get?
I got the acrylic stand and the poster.
Wow, I thought you liked me.
Why didn't you get more stuff?
Well, I left stuff for people to buy.
No, they have stuff to buy.
Get the most stuff.
Get free stuff from me.
Okay, Lime got standee, cozy keychain, other keychain, raid poster and the other poster and the sticker sheet.
See, at least Lime gets more stuff.
One.
Get a one.
Now.
But like...
Like, it would be such a shame to not use this item.
Like, I don't wanna be wasteful.
No, no, no.
You know what I mean?
But also, my game has been so fucking miserable.
Come on, you should just roll for your luck, you know?
It would be more fun to see what you roll.
I think I just gotta, you know, what if I left it all alone in my pocket?
I hope it's me.
Goddammit.
Oh my goodness!
Oh no!
I'll never leave the beach!
Oh my...
Vika, that was masterful.
I love you.
I'm fucking outta here.
And you can actually just use the thing?
Very good.
I'm going.
Oh dear.
I like how the train looks a little bit more like Santa's sleigh or something.
Sleigh!
Also, somebody's asking if it's possible for us to run out of stock.
So, the thing is, we pre-ordered a few stuff.
A lot of stuff.
And most of it is already half gone, but there's a lot of stuff that is done in-house.
Like the posters, the sticker sheet, the shirt, and what was the other thing?
Don't worry guys, I'll cut out stickers.
But don't worry, we're getting more stuff.
Very, very soon.
Because I think it's until January 15th.
I'm gonna sit there and cut them by hand.
Do it.
Oh no, this picture is the stuff that's actually done in-house, so it's fine.
How many shirts?
Last we heard, 1,500 shirts.
That's one thing that you girls didn't get on your thing, but when people get a shirt, they get a number.
So if somebody orders a shirt, on the side it's gonna be number 1501.
Unique, right?
Yeah, it's gonna be unique.
I can hear somebody mashing.
It's gonna be fun.
Okay, mash A.
I see.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Tranquilize the forest.
Oh my God, I started late.
It hurts!
Oh my God.
It hurts so bad.
Oh God.
That was not great.
I don't think mine was good either.
We all did decently.
Oh my God!
Just by one!
By one mint!
That's my baby girl, that's my mint.
The clutch, for real.
I'm gonna pay for that tomorrow, holy shit.
I know, my finger.
My carpal tunnel is like...
I have wrist issues.
I had a spot where I stopped for a full second.
You guys should have played Metal Gear Solid, I'm just saying.
Thank you, Kang!
Buddy, look at his little teeth!
Why did he come at the final two turns?
Yeah, it's like Joe Biden.
Buddy is here for a single turn.
Look, his teeth retracted.
I know, he's so huge.
I do wonder what kind of things...
Before hitting the dice move to a random space, that's not...
What?
Great, is it?
That sounds awful.
He's all the way over there, and we're all the way on the opposite side, so...
I mean, it might be good for you guys, yeah, because it could teleport you back up here a little bit.
That's true.
But there's no way we're getting to him in two turns.
Are we?
Get to him, run to him.
Oh my gosh, you're so close.
Eleven to the star.
I'd love to buy something, what do you got?
Can you make up for the fact that my dice rolls suck?
You can.
Imagine if they had a golden pipe.
I know, right?
Should I just get a triple dice?
Or...
I think you could get a double dice.
Might as well.
Yeah.
Yeah?
Let's see if I can't use it until next turn.
There's no way that Giga is gonna swipe the star, even though she could roll high and actually swipe the star, so it's gonna be fine.
I would never.
It was eleven from where you were.
Four to the star.
I wonder how far I am visualizing the star.
I am manifesting it right now.
Okay, okay, close your eyes.
Now imagine holding the star.
Imagine touching it.
I'm firmly grasping it right now.
It's stabbing my neck.
I'm dying, I'm dying.
I'm bleeding out.
I'm bleeding out of the hole.
It's so hot.
Despite all my rage, I am still just a ghost in a cage.
Go.
You're gonna go somewhere?
Now.
Oh, it was my turn.
Yes.
That's you on the left.
You chose Bowser.
I did, I did.
I'm sorry.
Why are you viewing the board like you're gonna get anything?
Come on.
Why are you mean to me?
Do the triple.
I wish I could duel you.
I'm gonna do the triple.
You already dueled me and you lost.
Get over it.
You know what's gonna happen?
I'm gonna get that star next turn with my triple dice.
And then the star is going to spawn in right ahead of me and I'm gonna run straight to the next star.
And it's gonna be great.
It's true.
Just you wait.
I hope it's gonna be the biggest comeback that has ever been envisioned.
The biggest rebound.
And then the game's gonna give me like three pity stars at the end.
It's gonna be good.
I hope the star comes to the beginning of the board.
It probably will.
What if it manifests right behind you?
That would be really sad.
So sad.
Yep, I've gifted subs for Mint.
The only thing that will make her happy.
The only thing that will make her happy is if you gift her subs.
God, so sad.
I need more people.
She needs more subs, you heard that?
Oh my god.
She's just never satisfied.
I'm never satisfied.
She loves Batara.
Thanks for the gifted memberships.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Thank you for the 50!
Thank you so much!
Thank you guys for the gifted.
Gifted, thank you.
You guys don't actually have to.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
All in, baby, all in, baby, all in, baby, all in, baby, all in, baby.
All in, baby, all in, baby.
Because I'm about to get 6 coins from this space.
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
Thank you guys, thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you!
Please, I'm satisfied.
I'm full, I'm full, I'm full, I'm full.
Thank you.
Fuzzy's so cute.
Wait, what is this?
Super Mario.
Nice, nice, nice.
I don't like the sheer amount of drift on this, holy shit.
Oh my God.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh my God, that was so close.
I love how...
Thank you for the commentary!
Sorry, I'm like, watching e-sports.
Oh my God, you almost got fucking destroyed there.
This one's fun to watch.
I wouldn't want to participate though.
A hit, a hit for Giga, a hit for Lime.
Oh my God.
Boom, Tetris for Giga.
Boom, Tetris for Lime.
Oh my God, Lime is killing it.
Giga is losing.
Oh my God, go, go!
Who are we cheering for, chat?
Who are we cheering for?
We're cheering for anybody, actually.
Lime, let's go Lime!
Come on, Lime!
Go Lime!
Lime is killing it right now.
Oh my God, go!
The only one who can beat Giga.
Nice.
113.
Nice throw in the butt.
I told you, I present in victory.
Thank you.
She won the battle, but Giga won the war.
Wait, it ain't over yet.
It ain't over yet.
Look at this.
Pretty!
Thank you!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm ready.
Oh gosh, I'm not ready.
Oh, this one is just coins though.
This one is not too bad.
What is this?
I don't think I've seen this one.
I say it in the sense that like...
Oh, I see.
I see.
Not coin.
Get out of the way!
Wait, I'm last.
Can I have a single coin?
Nope.
This is also practice, so don't worry about it.
Hey guys, you're supposed to be...
Please, a single coin.
Have one coin, please.
You're supposed to be gifting to Mint.
They are.
They have.
Don't worry.
I worry.
Stop, please!
Good!
I got punished for my hubris!
Go Mint!
Go!
Get all of them!
Oh my god.
I got punished for my hubris.
Yippee!
It is very scary on an auto-scroller like that when the game starts lagging.
Hey Pookie, how are you feeling?
Very good job, everybody.
We got big money there.
The entire game, it said no change.
The entire game.
What if I use my triple block and get free ones?
That would just kind of caps them off the screen.
Cinema.
Oh my god.
You are cinema.
Oh, never mind.
It'll do.
That'll do, Donkey.
That'll do.
Me!
Wait.
You know what to do.
You have the coins.
I have the coins.
And you'll have enough coins for the next star.
No!
I have the coins.
You have the coins.
Do it.
The comeback!
The comeback is real!
I repay Giga's kindness by stealing her coins.
First, don't leave it.
I'm sorry.
So cute.
I'm sorry, Giga.
Why are you apologizing?
Giga's been first the entire game.
But she hasn't personally wronged me.
Well, she has personally wronged me.
Yeah, and me.
That is true.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Where the hell is that?
It's over.
It's so over.
14 left.
You... 14 what left?
That her, she has movement left.
Oh, wow.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe I just wander around in circles here so I don't step on any of those fucking traps.
But as you know, it should be fine because I can count it.
How many did I say I have?
19,972.
I think that was it.
I have 13.
No, no.
Add 2 to that.
OK.
And then subtract 3.
And then divide by...
Uh-huh.
I'm with you so far.
Where are we carrying the 1?
44.
Yeah.
It's 44.
44.
Alright, Giga.
I mean, not Giga.
Shit.
I'm sorry.
You're all so small.
It's just...
Oh my god.
Just come on!
She always does this.
Limes is thinking.
Let her think.
Don't pass me.
Don't hurt yourself.
You'll regret it.
Wait, you might actually be able to get to the star.
It's a little horsey.
No, this is the last turn.
Oh, it is?
OK.
Yeah, it's the last turn.
Betrayal.
Oh.
I'm never... I haven't even... I haven't been past the Trade Station.
Wait, actually.
Hold on.
Editor.
Did you enjoy the bottom of the map, Mintz?
Did I what?
Did you enjoy the bottom of the map?
Yeah, I really liked seeing this part.
Real, real, real, real.
Can somebody add... My editor, can you double check if this is true when you added this?
What?
Make a little fact check in the notes of the... We have people clipping in the Discord and stuff.
Oh, how far I've been?
If you've actually never passed.
No, because I got run over.
The furthest I've gotten was because Lime called me for milk.
I got summoned for milk and stuff.
OK, you still don't have enough for the stupid star.
I put a three dice that I still don't have enough to either buy it or even afford it.
No way.
Oh, you're so close.
And I don't have the money.
Just open up and see what happens.
I did.
I did and then I got hurt.
And then I got hurt and it sucked.
I don't like opening up.
Wait, what does this do?
What does this do?
I'm scared.
No, no.
Oh, what's happening?
I'm in heaven, finally.
Chance time.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm gonna lose another star.
Oh wait, I missed Donkey.
I'm so sad.
Donkey?
Sorry, I meant DJ.
To me!
It's better than nothing.
Alright.
Sorry, I don't think she was...
Wait, did I actually sabotage Lime?
Lime is in second!
Lime has two stars!
There's no sabotaging!
No, she could've been first, because you got all of the coins.
There's still bonus stars, potentially, though.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Yeah, no, we might have bonus stars.
She still is not off the train platform.
Oh my god.
Yippee!
20!
I have so many coins.
287.
Oh my god.
You're gonna get a star from those coins, probably, Mint.
Ghost chicken!
Thank you for the message!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Yeah, I'll get that.
Maybe.
Yes, zero.
Tell Rubby to check in the game with the girls if Mint really truly never made it past the bottom.
It's true!
I have the most coins because I don't do anything.
I don't go anywhere.
Give me them coins.
Wait, not for me, please.
That's all I have.
Please.
But you wanna look so juicy.
No, please.
It's literally all I have.
Just take it from Tara.
She's the one doing the sub-a-thon.
Let's all bully the...
It's true.
You have been given enough.
Why are you bullying me?
I've given you free sub-ups.
What are you doing?
I invited you guys to the club.
Thank you.
You girls haven't even talked about my amazing merchandise.
Thank you so much.
You have!
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
You just ignored me.
MataraCon.shop.
Get your t-shirts.
Get your stickers.
You're reusing your voice from last year.
MataraCon.shop.
I had Yiga record a commercial for me last year.
Thank you for not having the train send me back to the beginning again.
Oh, you missed out.
You should've.
I would've gotten hit.
Do you think there is a got hit by this fucking train the most times, Stars?
Guys, knock me out when I'm down.
Cookie Cutter.
I'm already down.
Oh no, this is so much easier for you guys.
This game is so easy for you.
I have to remember three shapes.
Basically, I have to remember three shapes.
And you guys just have to call out one shape and you're good.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
We each own a cookie cutter and the right person has to cut one of their shapes.
Just look at your shape and...
Oh, I see.
OK, OK, OK.
I see.
OK.
Oh, OK, OK, OK.
That's not bad.
I get you.
OK.
It's so much easier for you guys.
Just wait for yours.
This is unfair for you, Ashley.
Some of the team games are such bullshit.
I know.
Alright, here we go.
Look at which one you are and remember it.
I am...
I am Mushroom.
Go!
Go?
OK.
Maybe we should go?
Please don't distract me, guys.
Please, please, please.
Matara, talk about your merch.
Talk about your merch.
Matara, Matara, Matara.
Look, look, look, look.
Oh my God.
Matara, look.
Matara.
Oh my God.
Wait, someone's raiding you.
Matara, someone's raiding you.
You have to say thank you.
You have to say thank you, Matara.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara.
Matara, star, star, star, star.
I actually clocked in.
You did.
Wait, it's lagging.
Very good.
Uninstalled this game in every game ever.
This was rigged in your favor.
This is because you played two games before this.
Yeah, yeah.
I was on the three.
I was on the three team.
Now it's time for the results.
Hooray!
I wonder who won.
Actually, genuinely, it could be Limes or Higa.
I mean, depending on the bonus stars, it could also decide to give, like, two pity stars to someone or something like that.
That's true.
To Mint and she wins.
It's possible.
I kind of want Mint to win.
I think it would be really funny.
Star distribution.
This is messed up.
This is so messed up.
Messed up, dude.
Look at that.
Present the bonus stars.
Rich bo... It's Mint!
Please me.
I wonder who's it gonna be.
Hooray!
Oh my god, I'd like to thank my mom.
I'm gonna thank your mom at Thanksgiving.
That's what I'm gonna be thankful for at Thanksgiving.
Yoshi!
Could it be?
The comeback?
I've never won.
That's bullshit.
Wait.
There's only two bonus!
I earned mine and you paid for yours at the end.
I hate these rich people, man.
Oh my god.
Mine's malicious.
I have to say it's all fucking skill.
It's such random bullshit.
Oh my god.
The finer details.
Okay.
I hate Mario Party.
Get a lot of coins.
Wait, most shopping?
I think I shopped like once.
Oh no, I didn't.
I got zero stars, so I didn't actually win the most minigames.
I mean, you did, it's just not a bonus star.
So congratulations on winning the minigames.
I got 351 coins?
What the hell?
Oh my god.
I got the star and whatever the heck that was.
Nice.
I don't understand.
Wait, is this the minigame?
Mario Party is so dumb, dude.
It's like someone will be like absolutely cruising and then just...
It was like, nah.
Nah.
Oh my god.
Oh, number... Okay, number of minigames won.
Oh yeah, you got the most.
Yeah.
Really?
Number of items won.
But number of items used?
You used a lot too.
What's this one?
Number of reactions used?
I used 67 reactions.
Wait, did I win number of reactions?
No, I did.
You did?
Oh man, I need to Yoshi what more.
Oh my god, I actually won the minigames.
What?
That's so unlike me.
Yeah.
That never happens.
Got fourth pla... Wait, I got fourth place?
What happened?
Cause you're dumb.
No, I think it was because that was the one for the host.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, that was the host.
Wait, let's go to the party plaza so we can get more reactions.
Yeah, let's buy some and spam them.
I'm gonna buy some, yeah.
Also, she's not dumb.
I love you.
Who's dumb?
My voice is like really starting to give out and we're on day two.
I know, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
I think it's because I... Since I'm in the basement, I put heating in my room when I went to bed.
So I think I'm also just, you know, all old and dried up.
It won't let me buy.
Oh, I don't think we can... Yeah, we have to be in our own plazas because Nintendo.
No!
Alright, what are we buying?
How do I buy stuff?
You can't.
You cannot in this room.
Yeah.
You would have to leave.
Okay, I'm outta here.
I wanna spend my coins.
Yeah, let me spend my coins.
If you wanna leave and just buy stuff in Discord and talk about it...
Because I don't think... If it's okay, usually I play another game, but I haven't had time to do...
The problem with streaming all the time is that I'm also like answering my managers, planning collabs.
So I have a lot of admin stuff I have to do.
That's why you wanna end it here?
Lunch break.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If that's okay.
But we can still yap a little bit.
I just...
I just definitely need to like, you know, answer.
I have so many people messaging me about stuff, but I need to send out an app for everybody.
Okay.
I didn't realize it's actually like, you know, I'm here all day.
What did you think?
A 24-hour sub-a-thon?
I can't believe that a 24-hour sub-a-thon is for 24 hours a day.
24 hours?
Shit!
No, actually, it's little stuff, right?
Like my manager...
My manager asking me about stuff and things like that.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm a professional button masher.
Party points to go shopping at the Party Plaza shops.
Keep playing to collect more points.
I'm trying to do like the Nintendo voice, but I ruined it at the end.
I'm getting achievements.
Here, I'll do it too.
Earning achievements grants you rewards for raising your player rank.
That was perfect.
Thanks.
Can you imagine if Toad did all of the announcements?
Like just fucking incomprehensible Nintendo announcements the entire time.
It's like when Donald Duck speaks anytime.
Dude, they made a battle pass.
Yeah, they did.
Oh shit, the Nintendo battle pass.
Hell yeah.
Hit!
There's a hit.
Is there a miss?
I like how there's a reaction shop.
There's no miss!
Where do I buy the stickers, by the way?
No, there's no miss!
Presumably the reaction shop.
Yeah, it's the reaction shop.
Where's the reaction shop?
I don't know which one it is, and if you press the wrong one, it's probably gonna give you like a 5 minute tutorial, so good luck.
These are fun.
I'm going to another island.
There's a good game.
I know which one the reaction shop is, I'm not telling you.
It actually says on the top left.
You have to be like, I love you, and then that's it.
That's what I get.
You jerk.
Which one, guys?
I have enough for one more.
They only have like one page of stickers.
I know!
They don't have the good ones.
Wait, you only have enough for one more?
How many did you buy?
Two.
Okay.
Is this stickers?
I like the lucky you one because it feels kind of sarcastic.
Like, lucky you!
It does feel kind of...
I'm gonna be so sarcastic with it.
Lucky you!
Oh, you're so right.
I should've gotten the lucky you.
I'm gonna do all me as well.
Actually, I got wow.
That's pretty sarcastic too.
Wow is pretty good.
I'm gonna get good game.
Good game.
GG.
GG is a good one.
Bad luck.
Or wah.
I think if you utterly ruin someone in a mini game, you should just say good game after.
There's 109 of them.
Wow.
Oh, you have to unlock more, I think.
There's the one that just aggressively tells you to hit.
I'm taking that one.
Yeah, I got that one too.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I can buy all of them, by the way.
You played three games.
Haha.
Yeah.
Create your own Mario party card.
I'm okay.
Wow.
What's this one?
Collect groovy music.
Wait, I have to pay you for music, Nintendo?
What if I just go to YouTube?
What are you gonna do then?
No, no, no.
You'd probably DMCA more people.
Oh, add my stickers.
Oh my gosh, I'm making my little... Oh, Metal Gear.
Oh wait, how do I add them to my stickers?
I think you can just scroll through all of them, but you can also do shortcuts.
So you can quickfire BM people.
I'm gonna edit my reaction shortcuts for all the times that I play this game.
I have a question that's gonna test our friendship.
Wait, this looks like a box.
Girls?
Yeah.
Are you cool to stay and call with me while I take a shower?
What the hell?
I'm gonna mute.
I just haven't had time to shower.
Why don't you take us with you?
That is the true friendship test.
We'll wash you.
Or we could just watch.
Whichever you prefer.
Can I trust you all to babysit my stream?
Because I haven't had time to take a shower at all.
That's fine.
We'll hang out.
Yeah, I guess we'll hang out.
And sit here in awkward silence.
Yeah, I guess.
I suppose.
Come on, don't do that.
I'm gonna leave you girls in Big Momo and everything.
I'll be stupid.
You can't say stinky anymore.
I'm so stinky.
Yeah, you can't call anyone else stinky if you're literally nasty right now.
Stink bug over here.
Alright, I got the ultimate BM shortcut list.
I've got good game, and then I got the Yoshi presenting, and then I got lucky you, and then I got all me.
Hell yeah, let's do it.
All me.
It's perfect.
Oh, I'm gonna go... You can take pictures, like, in the...
On the, like, the map.
And then you get... You have a little photo album.
It's kinda cute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Time to go look for photos, guys.
I'm putting stickers on my card.
I made mine, too.
When Mata was like, can you sit here when I take a shower?
I was like, wait, how long does that take?
Because for me, when I take a shower, I have to diffuse my hair for, like, 25 minutes, so shower is basically an hour-long commitment.
And I was like, yeah, let's go.
Yeah, actually, how long of a... She didn't mention how long this will be.
Are we, like, showering skincare?
Are we showering and wash that hair?
It doesn't matter.
It can vary a lot.
Yeah, because my skincare, like, takes up half the routine.
Oh, God.
Yeah, exactly.
Do you, like, have the whole, like, 12-step going on?
I used to.
I don't do it anymore, but I have, like, the 12-step skincare.
Mine's... I don't know how many, but it's, like, it's up there.
Wait, now I can play as Pauline!
Because I took a picture of her.
Congratulations.
Oh, you just run up to her and snap a photo, and then you can, like, skinwalk?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I'm, like, literally taking her identity.
Yoink.
Takes her face.
You gotta hit me with that skincare routine, because as my chat will attest, I am, like, an absolute skincare fiend.
And if someone, like, baits me with a skincare question, it's like, oh, okay, we deal with the chat for the next 25 minutes.
Let's go.
I don't know what I'm doing, though.
Maybe I need help from you.
Let's discuss.
We can compare notes.
I just talk to them about sunscreen every day.
Yes!
Wear your sunscreen, chat!
Sunscreen advocates, go!
What are your favorite sunscreens?
Oh, man.
If I want one that doesn't cost me a billion dollars, the Pure Aqua Rich Watery Essence.
But they keep reformulating it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you want something similar, I would try the Skin Aqua UV Moisture Milk.
I have that one, too.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, no, that one, I love that one.
I have, like, ten different sunscreens.
Yeah, they don't reformulate it every ten seconds, so I like it more.
Oh, yeah.
Nice, yeah.
Yeah, and then for the other one...
That's probably the bigger one, yeah.
Yeah, the other one that I use is the... I think it might be Europe only, but it's, like, a La Roche-Posay one.
Oh, I love La Roche-Posay!
I'm not here for me to, like, fucking butcher that name, but...
Yeah, no, it's...
It's called the UV Mune 400, and it's, like, a cream.
And it's got, like, the newest European filters, and it's, like, hell yeah.
Ooh!
Yeah.
I think that is the reason why I got yelled at in LA, because this guy was like, You need sun.
It's like, I've been out in the sun every day, you just can't tell!
You just get...
I'm just protected in my little sun hat with my sunscreen.
Two on point.
No, I feel that.
I wear sunscreen all the time.
If I don't, I can get, like, really cooked.
Yeah, yeah, I use... I use, um...
Tretinoin?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so I have to wear sunscreen.
If I don't, I am in a lot of trouble.
So it's like, oh no.
I don't know what mine is.
I just get whatever's popular at Cosme when I go to Harajuku.
Yeah.
I mean, that's also valid.
Like, if you're not sensitive, I wish my skin was less sensitive, because, like, a lot of stuff will, like, I'll have...
I'll go red, or I'll clog up, so I'm very...
Like, I love skincare, but when I find things that work, I stick to them like glue.
And then I see people being like, I got to experiment with all of these things, and nothing bad happened, and I'm like, you bitch.
No!
How dare you!
It's okay, I don't have nice skin, though.
Don't feel jealous.
No, I bet your skin is great.
We are our own worst critics.
Like, you know, I'll look at mine and be like, oh, I can see, like, a little bit, like, a tiny bit of acne scarring from, like, ten years ago, and nobody else can see it.
Everyone's like, no, you...
But I can!
Yeah, they'll be like, literally, your skin is flawless, and it's like, no, I can see the scars.
Yeah, and everyone has that problem where, like, they, like, super zoom in, like, they stand right up to the mirror.
Yeah, yeah, like, you're basically, like, kissing the mirror, and then you're like, why can I see all these imperfections?
And then no one's walking up to you and, like, standing that close and being like, damn, girl, your skin looks crazy.
It's me.
I am.
It's like, wow, I can see your sebaceous filaments right now, and it's disgusting.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Let me use my salicylic acid to clean my nose.
The first time I said the word salicylic acid on stream, people were like, you use acid on your skin?
It's like, yes.
Yes, you have to.
You have to.
Yeah.
If you don't, you die.
Yeah, the way that it works is, obviously, you put acid on your skin, it burns away the top layer, and then you have new skin.
Yeah, easy.
That's why it's called an acid.
Obviously, obviously.
My game is bugged.
What's happening?
Your game is bugged?
I already left.
I got my stickers.
I have nothing else to do.
I have one Mario party.
Yeah.
You've done it all.
You did it.
What if Matara's not taking a shower?
What if she takes a bath and just, like, leaves us?
Oh my God.
I don't doubt it.
I don't doubt it at all.
Like, in two hours time, she comes back and she's like, hey guys, how was it?
And it's like, we now know everything about skin care there was ever to know.
We have pooled our knowledge and ascended.
My game... Oh, wait.
Yeah.
My game is bugged, everybody.
I cannot play the game.
What did you do to it?
I'm trying to play the Rhythm Kitchen and it's not letting me.
My... Actually, my Joy-Con just stopped working.
My Joy-Con stopped working.
Yeah, you know what?
No longer have skin.
I actually would find it kind of chill to just sit and play Mario Party minigames with, like, no stakes, because they're honestly kind of little fun bite-sized chunks.
Yeah, actually so fun.
Yeah, like, I think after one session...
We'll do that, like, after.
Yeah, like, at one session, we just sat there doing, like, minigames for a little bit, which was nice.
Yeah.
It's the same thing with, like, you know, Among Us.
I don't actually like the social thing.
Whenever someone, like, pulls the meeting button and it's like, oh man, I have to listen to people yell, just let me go back and press the button again.
I want to put one wire over to another.
Just leave me alone.
And then I get the bad guy and I'm like, no, let me just be a stunted person so I can do the tusks.
No, I agree, though.
I just like to run around and do them.
Guys, it won't let me do the thing.
It's just relaxing.
It's only letting me use my right Joy-Con.
And then when I press right, it won't press A.
This is my before bed.
Just let me enter the zone.
Oh my gosh, I think it was my...
My right Joy-Con is bad.
Wait, it won't let...
I just...
Leave, leave, leave.
Oh my gosh, it was there.
Am I on, like, tilt controls?
What is this?
Leave!
No!
It's like when people are like, how can you just grind in a video game?
Leave, there we go.
No, please let me leave.
At the same time, I'm receiving very...
Oh, I have to turn my Joy-Con sideways.
Yeah, that's like...
There's certain games that I want to play on stream, but I think about it and I'm like...
My Joy-Con is only on my right Joy-Con.
How do I make my left Joy-Con come back to me?
I just press buttons.
I'm on a single Joy-Con!
No!
Help me!
The rhythm game changed it.
And I don't usually have many off-stream games, but it's nice because, like, when you do a dungeon in that game, it's kind of just like...
You know, like, Tartarus and Persona 3.
Yeah, it's like that, and it's just like, you know, mindlessly going through, and then I refill my MP, and then I fight the thing, and it's just...
Yeah, it's just cozy, and I could stream it, but I could also just, you know...
Try to put it on my Steam Deck and switch off to the world.
Curl up in bed.
I like... It depends on the game.
Some games, I like when they're kind of repetitive like that to stream, because then I can just talk over it, and it's basically a just chatting stream.
While my hands are moving, but then there are other games where I have to lock in a little bit.
There are a lot of little things to remember, and I can't.
Yeah.
Like if there's resource management, right?
Like a city builder or something, I can't.
Like, I could kind of stream it, but I don't expect myself to do well at all.
Yeah, I have another game against the storm that I...
Yeah, I love that game.
That is a really fun off-stream game.
But because... Yeah, I could stream that one, but again, especially with city builders, I spend a lot of time silently staring at it and fast forward to see what's going on.
It's just like, this wouldn't be fun to watch.
Exactly.
Although some people are there just for, you know, hanging out.
Yeah, some people just want to chill and watch.
I think my game for that is RimWorld.
Like, I always go back to RimWorld because, like, there's enough happening with, like, goofy shit that the game is doing, but a lot of the time I'm also just, like...
Going back and forth with chat.
So it's nice.
Wait, there's a place called Minigame Bay.
Are all the minigames there?
You're gonna play minigames?
Minigame?
We can minigame.
I already jumped out, unfortunately.
I was like... I thought Matara said that she's, like, gonna do admin, right?
Yeah.
I think so.
Yeah, yeah, she won't be playing.
She won't be playing any games.
No, she won't be playing anything.
She doesn't need the practice anymore.
She hates video games.
She hates them.
I can't imagine.
That's, like... I'm probably not gonna do a sub-a-thon ever because I have so much stuff that I do.
And, like, I play a lot of games off-stream, but I'm always multitasking when I'm doing that.
Me too!
Oh my god, she's back in.
Hi.
I took a really fast shower.
That was fast.
Yeah, I was expecting it to be, like, 40 minutes.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
I wouldn't let you.
Yeah, I said to them when you left, I was like, well, when I take a shower, it's like an hour-long commitment because I'm diffusing my hair afterwards.
Are we in for the long haul?
I mean, it's fine, but...
Did you properly wash?
I did a quick wash.
A quick wash.
Did you, though?
So, it's only, like, you know, like in the Sims where you only let your Sim take half a shower and they're still half-asleep?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No soap, no nothing, no rubbing, no nothing, you know?
You'd be still underneath a waterfall for a second.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I just let the water fall for just a moment, yeah.
They were still baby-sitters.
Oh, really?
They said Yachi did a good job babysitting.
Did we do a good job, everybody?
You're just saying that.
We told Chat to use sunscreen because it's important.
Yeah.
Hey, I haven't seen most of these.
There are a lot, like, over the years, there are a lot of Mario Party minigames, like, a lot of the time...
Oh, yeah.
I only really play when I get invited to play, so pretty much every time it's a brand new set of minigames.
Same, same.
I never played Mario Party until I became a VTuber.
I think my first Mario Party was actually, like, two years ago.
Yeah, me too.
I played Mario Party on the Nintendo 64 when I was a kid, and then that's it, right up until now.
Like, basically, right up until you, like, until basically Mata started inviting me to play Mario Party, that was it.
And it was just like, this isn't the Mario Party I remember.
It's very different.
I played all of them.
I don't know, I really miss...
With a lot of the older ones, they were really, like, customized.
So you used to, like, if you go to Spooky Map, you'd have this little storyline going on when you enter in, and then you're wearing, like, wizard outfits.
Right?
I like that for the old ones.
Mommy's dead.
Yeah, it was also nice, because obviously, like, it's all local, so the game doesn't decide to just chug out halfway through.
Oh, in the way that it would before, right?
Yeah, I mean, I only have a Switch now for only Mario Party and Mario Kart, genuinely.
I very rarely play things on my Switch, unless I'm streaming them.
I only play Switch games if, like, it's only on the Switch.
Otherwise, I would like to play any other platform.
Like, even if portability would be nice, I'll try and get it on PC and use my Steam Deck or something, because my Switch makes me sad.
I lay in bed every day with my Steam Deck.
I thought for a second you said, I lay on your bed.
I was like, okay.
With my Steam Deck, I do.
With your Steam Deck.
Just, like, waiting there, like, hello.
They're gonna organize it and hang out with us.
What are you thinking about, Nu?
Playing Throne Fall, girl.
Wait, is that what you've been... I was gonna ask that as next.
What's the... What have y'all been playing lately?
Holo Cure.
Holo Cure?
Throne Fall.
Is that the one that you've been playing?
Have you streamed Throne Fall?
Me?
Yeah, I streamed it two days in a row.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I've seen this one.
It's cute.
It's lightweight.
Very lightweight.
And it plays well with the controller.
Am I holding a Pikabit Lime?
Because my hands are full of lotion.
Sorry?
Can you send me a Pikabit on Discord?
Full of lotion.
The amount of times...
Which one's Holo Cure?
The amount of times what?
The amount of times when we were in Japan, you're like, I can't do this, my hands are full of lotion.
Genuinely, if you've washed your hands to apply your skincare, you thus have no hands until the skincare is finished.
Yeah, it's so true.
Otherwise, you have to wash your hands again.
Yeah, otherwise you've got to wash your hands again.
You know, if the doorbell goes, oh, God, I'm just... I'm incapable of answering the doorbell.
I guess that's getting missed.
So wait, it's a tower defense to, like, protect your city?
Um, sort of, yeah.
Protect London.
City of London.
That looks like London to me.
It looks very familiar.
Yeah, it looks just like London.
Is Hololive the Fighting League of London?
It's like Vampire Survivors.
Oh, that one.
I know which one it is.
The Hololive Cute Anime Girls, I love them.
Who's your most OP person to play with when you play Moon?
Oh, I've been playing a lot of Risu because she's good with the money.
Oh, I love Risu.
She's also very cute.
She's such a crazy good singer too.
I know.
I'm playing mini-games.
That's how I like it about it.
I'm playing a mini-game.
Mini-game, mini-game, mini-game.
I'm gonna answer an email.
That's exciting.
If you're doing admin, I'm doing admin.
Oh, are we all doing admin?
Are we admin time?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Let's do it.
Cute girls co-working together cutely.
I'm gonna leave.
I'm gonna leave that.
Also, I have an update.
I have an update.
Already, some folks in LA have gotten their Matara merch.
Oh my god!
My agent at WME just sent me this photo and said the office has officially been Matara-fied.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Are they managers?
I'm not sure what to call them.
It's probably smelly in there.
Hey, hey.
Take it back.
No, I won't.
I won't.
Take it back, you little shit.
Oh, shoot.
That was so good.
My bread.
Y'all are getting yours soon.
Yippee!
Hell yeah.
I'm looking forward to it.
The posters were fucking amazing.
I know.
Everything looks so good.
Thank you, guys.
Everybody, get your orders in.
I know.
And again, it was a really, really big thing and I'm really happy.
They're gonna be here until Japan.
Oh, Japan.
Until January 15th.
So don't worry.
January 15th.
Japan 15th.
You can use your... What is it called?
You can use your Christmas money for it.
There is a few things that are getting a little bit low on stock, but we are gonna up them.
And I know if you're European or in Asia or Oceania, the shipping is very expensive.
The big... is North American and let's start through one region and then maybe we can...
Are they made to order or...?
I think it was a bit of both, right?
Didn't you, like, have some made beforehand?
The shower did me good.
What?
Uh-oh, I think Matara lagged out.
I think so too.
Because she went robot for a second.
I'm so sorry, guys.
My Discord actually cut out and I could not hear you.
Yeah, we know.
I wasn't trying to talk over you.
I was trying to answer your question and you were like...
I'm gonna talk about my shower.
I got, like, a lag and for some reason, I don't know what happened.
Like, my Discord cut out and I couldn't hear anything.
It was so funny.
Oh my God.
Uh-oh, I actually see my voice connection actually dipping back and forth, so maybe the Discord is...
Uh-oh.
It was you.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's you.
Yeah, I just pushed Twinkie again.
I was hoping it was just me.
Damn.
I'm gonna step out though.
I gotta go walk my dogs because they're small and annoying.
It was really fun hanging out with you guys.
It was just so fun.
You're winning.
Your first victory.
Yippee!
Yeah, I won for once.
It felt so very earnest.
It was some fucking bullshit.
Oh, bye, Mata.
Bye, Mata.
What?
You cut out again for me, I promise.
It's you.
Okay, I'm gonna go to...
I just thought you abruptly decided that was it.
Bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.
Thanks for gaming.
Thank you.
That was so fun, you guys.
That was so fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed our Mario parties.
Guys, I got cheated real bad, didn't I?
I'm still using one Joy-Con, by the way.
Guys, I was supposed to have the comeback.
What happened?
The train was too dangerous.
It's true.
I love the skin care chat.
Really?
Would you actually want us to talk more about skin care?
I know maybe it's... I'm not an expert or anything.
I just... I kind of just go to the store and get what's popular.
Like in Harajuku, there's a place called Cosme.
And they have like the most popular skin cares for the month or whatever in the middle.
And I just go and I'm like...
And I get those.
Usually.
As a guy, I know nothing about skin care.
As a male, skin care is an alien concept.
It can be as difficult or rather it can be as simple or as complicated as you want.
But honestly, just wearing sunscreen is the most important part of it.
If you got anything out of our conversation, wear sunscreen.
Yes.
And it doesn't... And if you're just like...
Oh, but sunscreen makes my face so oily.
No, no, no.
There's such nice sunscreens now that aren't like...
That don't make your face greasy and stuff, you know?
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna go get mine because I really like mine.
Like I said, I got it at the Cosme, but I can't remember the name of it.
It's not Kose, I think.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
It's right in the room next to me.
Pause, join the party.
I can't remember on the podcast you guys talked about this pimple patch with microneedles.
Do you have the brand name?
If you just look that up, you will find a bajillion of them.
But hold on.
Pause, come here, baby.
Little Pause went to the vet today for the first time.
She went to the vet today for the first time since I got her.
Yeah, and I was really nervous.
I was just like, is she gonna be a good cat or is she gonna rip their faces off?
But she was a good cat, they said.
They said that all she was was a little chatty.
And I told them, I was just like, when I first got Pies, I like, think I got scammed because I was like, oh, you know, what kind of cat is she?
And they were like, she's a lap cat.
She's so sweet.
Which she is.
Hey, what are you doing?
She gave me a funny look.
She's so sweet, but they're like, she's a lap cat.
She'll always be next to you.
She'll always be in your lap.
She'll always be this.
Never.
Only once has she ever laid in my lap.
And then also, I was like, does she talk a lot?
And they were like, no, she doesn't really meow ever.
And at the vet, they were like, she's so chatty.
Axel, welcome to Membo Ship.
I got my sunscreen.
It's Kanebo Veil of Day.
It makes your face...
It's a little on the pricier side, I'll admit.
But it makes your...
Your face doesn't feel greasy.
It's very mattifying.
So it makes your face feel very smooth.
Kanebo.
Kanebo is dollar, dollar, dollar.
I know.
It was at Cosme that I got it.
I think this was 3,000 yen.
So it is a little more pricier.
But I've had it for a long time.
It's so yummy.
Not to eat, sorry.
To smell.
JP sunscreen is goaded.
I don't get stuff from the US because...
The US's sunscreen stuff is very outdated.
The laws for sunscreen is very outdated.
They haven't updated it in like...
I think it's like 20 years or something crazy.
A lot of sunscreens outside of the US have better coverage than stuff in the US.
That's why I never buy sunscreen in the US.
I always buy it out of the US.
That's why whenever I go to Japan I get new stuff.
Sometimes they are greasy and stuff and I don't like them.
YesStyle carries the Kanebo sunscreen in case anyone wants to buy it.
Oh, there you go.
Oh my gosh, I used to buy from YesStyle all the time.
Used to get from YesStyle all the time.
Best sunscreen, stay home.
So true.
What SPF is it?
SPF 50.
SPF 50, which I think is really like the max you truly need.
Pies, where did you go?
Where did you go?
I think she is hiding behind the curtain.
Well guys...
I guess I'll head out, this is fun.
I hope you guys enjoyed our Mario party.
Maybe I can... I would love to try a different map.
Or I could try that map and actually use it.
Actually go through the map, maybe.
Maybe I can actually explore next time, who knows.
Who knows.
But yeah, this was a lot of fun.
Thank you Mataro for inviting me.
I'm glad I could collab with Giga for the first time.
And Limu had the best comeback ever, it was so awesome.
Thanks for the fun collab and the bonus sunscreen talk.
What do you want, girly?
You're sweet, sweet girl.
Yeah, you're so sweet, I love you.
She's so cute, you're so cute, aren't you?
You're so cute and you know it.
Yeah, you do.
You're so cute.
My tiny little baby girl.
Yeah.
Eyes.
Look at me, look at me.
Stop, stop looking at that.
Look at me.
Yeah.
Look at you.
She's tired today because she had to get shots.
And I had to tell the vet that she's had diarrhea for a long time.
And so they're checking her for worms and parasites.
Which you would think that...
The shelter I got her from would have checked for that.
But they didn't say anything.
I have no idea.
Sunscreen fun, since you keep eating it.
No, this has lasted me forever, but thank you.
Thanks for the fun collab and enjoying all these collabs with Laimu.
Thanks, make me!
Make me the pink, yeah.
I love Laimu, she's so cute.
Vocal parasites.
How big of a bottle?
It's not that big.
I'll be honest, I don't use it everyday.
But I've been using it...
I use it when I go outside, obviously.
I use it everyday in Japan.
And it still has lasted me.
I'm gonna say that and it's probably...
It's considerably lighter now.
But, you know.
I say that and now, like, tomorrow it'll be all gone.
I had a shelter kitty who had been dewormed.
I had to deworm her again anyway.
It happens.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Can you... Wait.
Thanks for the stream in.
Maybe you can drag people into Dokapon Kingdom next time.
Also, kisses to Paws and Butaro.
Thank you!
Also, Ashes, thank you for the...
For the...
New Joy-Con funds.
No, my Joy-Cons are fine.
That was earlier.
Sorry, I missed it.
And also, MintyFreshBooty.
This was from earlier, but I think it was off stream.
Missed your birthday stream, so happy birthday.
Thank you!
Dokapon Kingdom.
I think Matara would like a Dokapon.
Probably.
Don't inflict Dokapon on people.
Oh, I've been wanting to inflict Dokapon on...
On two people for so long.
Dokapon.
One day.
Someday.
If you guys don't know what Dokapon Kingdom is...
If you think that Mario Party is the friendship killer...
No, no, no.
You are not ready for the true friendship killer of Dokapon Kingdom.
Dokopane Kingdom.
So true.
I've heard it's bad, but never played it.
It is the absolutely most ruthless unfair game you'll ever experience.
It's so bad.
It is so...
Okay.
Yeah, it's four players.
I recommend it with friends and family.
If you are ready to have none of those ever again.
Thank you guys for today!
I'll see you guys when I see you next.
And...
Have a nice day!
Bye bye!
Thank you everyone.
Thanks for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
I really appreciate it.
Bye bye, bye bye, bye bye!
Thank you!
See you!
Bye bye!